today the guest is football star and
entrepreneur Marco Reus
[music]
is mine too in Dortmund it's always
a shame to see that we
sign incredibly good players
young players
they unfortunately just have the dream of
wanting to play somewhere else after
two three four years maybe and
just to develop further there
because you always have the feeling okay now
you could build a team and
then in two years the team breaks up
again because two three good
players just leave and just
look at which players we really had with them in the
last few years
I think we would if they stayed
together like this and I think we'd
shave some things in Europe
[music]
[applause]
Welcome to the OMR podcast with
Philipp
Westermeier I'd particularly like to
point out companies that lead their respective categories on our software
evaluation platform at OMR Reviews
this is
the case with Kaya Kaya ca y a leads the
Document management category, that
is, they take care of it when you
receive documents by email or even
by post or whatever for
the automatically imported into the Kaya platform
, be it as a scan or
as an automatic redirection, at least
the whole company can then open
Accessing the document Editing
Organizing everything
that needs to happen with the document All of this makes Kaja
possible Automatically forward
Edit Notes Also integrate
with other software products that are often used
in companies, such as
Outlook Dropbox or personio. A
surprising number of former OMR Podcast
guests use Kaya in their companies  For
example, the colleagues from Sella x
mcmakler Tier uses Kaya everywhere
if you want to try it out yourself,
simply go to Kaya ca y
a.com and enter the voucher code OMR
there and then you get a
50% discount on the respective
business accounts for the first five months  a p  aar days
our tik tok challenge started
inspired by the sampa and the podcast
that I did with Philipp
Brückler you could hear everything in the
episode with knossi at the end
anyway it worked so well
that a lot of people started tiktok accounts
and  then used the hashtag OMR
cuts the best cut outs
from our podcast video podcasts if
you also used a lot of material about the
podcast here on
YouTube and sometimes generated 100,000
or million views on
tiktok say we noticed that too
practice in the charts then
shot up really well when
you found a lot of new heights I think
those who saw on tiktok
that we exist saw these scraps of
conversation and then apparently
decided the whole podcast
is mega mega work by a lot of
people behind it  the accounts Accounts
are usually not called like people then
somehow OM  R something so our
brand is also used our logo was
n't quite planned but in the
end it doesn't matter but it
more than fulfilled its purpose I'm grateful
to everyone who took part of course really
and of course some also
won because now the 5000
euros, we are paying a total of
20,000 euros, i.e. 4 x 5000 euros,
we will contact
those responsible for the accounts directly, so
send the DM and if you
speak then post and publish
who it is that we can
say really credibly and authentically hey
We didn't pay out the money according to
the motto somehow, we just tell it
and we will
pay it out to the respective accounts
that we liked the most, which
also generated the greatest reach
, so rely on it, it will come
out, thank you to all of them
participated you can
now let it be my colleagues at school
Team will be happy if our own
brand becomes more visible again and
all the accounts are no longer created again
, so thank you very much, of
course, as a football fan, I was looking forward to
the podcast with Marco Reus, but it was
n’t about football,
it was about everything  his
business he has been an entrepreneur for two years
has started
to found or build a beverage brand that
has been on the market for a few weeks now
the company is called repeat he
does it with partners why beverages
water is the goal how much money in the has
measured everything  we also
discussed the anecdote of how he
mixed it himself at Rewe and at Edeka here
in Hamburg, partly convinced an old
sports colleague
who was well-known in sports that his Rewe stores
sell a lot of drinks and
food business, but of
course also a bit of
sports business from the perspective of an
active  Of course I could
n't resist a few s  to ask port
questions, a few leadership principles
from Jürgen Klopp and the answer to the
question of why he actually prefers to watch the Premier
League over the Bundesliga let
's talk to Marcos
Marco Reus from Marco yes hello
you have to say so captain so case
the competitive athlete but  meanwhile
also about two other disciplines you
have one of the largest German social
media accounts ever so really
we also talk Pamela Reifen everything
yes I honestly
don’t see myself as an influencer I
really have to say now but if you say that
then I’m happy of
course but will  probably my
future career will not be a big
influenza but how do you explain
that so I mean to start in it's
amazing the two bigger
accounts than yours from German
footballers Toni Kroos and Mesut Özil have
and it's kind of logical because they
play  stop abroad then
have fun  niche fans German fans
or Turkish fans English fans
even with you you
now only play in Dortmund, so to speak,
that means you don’t have
any other
fan groups anyway, so it’s still a lot bigger
than others where is
I don’t know, so Dortmund is a
big club  and I think we
already have a lot of fans around the world, of course,
I think
you probably have even
bigger fans around the world at Real Madrid now, to
be honest, I don't even know
because I'm not really that blatantly
active, because of course
I post on Instagram  from time to time photos but
very very rarely private photos
I don't know how it came about
I have to be honest so
I sometimes surprise myself from time to time
but of course I'm happy that over
the years you've built up such a fan base, I would say
you don't
say anything commercial, there are
all the big US superstars
who somehow have
that  Money that they get from clubs
and then they also have deals
with sporting goods companies on the side,
so I mean they do a
whole range of things on the side, like you
have a startup, we
talk about it, but there are other big partnerships, so to speak,
that you
you say okay i also have the one with the
boss or with someone
no really honestly not at the moment
it was like that in the past what you a
little bit more
yes that's actually stayed a
little bit at the beginning i
always chose a little bit
because  Of course you look okay in which
areas you would like to be seen
, which you just think is cool,
but meanwhile yes I am 33 too and
yes you can no
longer choose where you would like to go
but of course I am relatively open
and  if something comes up again at some point
, then I'm also open
to
it, but it's not like that now  ch
absolutely has to do it now or
would like to
do it, yes, that's the way that
saying that also for disadvantages makes
you worried and at 33, so
to speak,
football pro age is at least somehow
foreseeable you think about it
according to the motto how long can it
actually go and  what do I do then,
what does that mean now,
if you could still play somewhere
in four five years, probably
somewhere in Qatar or in the USA
or something like that
, of course, you think about it
, it's quite normal, so the
process has already taken
place  I think when you're in your early 30s,
when you're in your 30s, that's
also a magic number for a footballer
in my eyes and of
course you think about it, okay, what
do you want to do in your career afterwards and it's the
same for me of course and  now
with the repeat that we have built up
there, the first step for me
even after my career is simply
here  to be well prepared also
to get to know something else
outside of football
and I think there are so many
doors open and then we'll let
repeat speak it's the first start, so to speak,
but the first participation, so to speak,
the first the first business
deal with which you  now
I mean there are a
few
players or professionals in your generation
who have made the investments. It's
the first thing you do where you
connect your name a bit
yes absolutely
yes it actually started that I
I've been thinking for a long time, of course,
when you get out of sports you drink
water every day, you take healthy drinks every day,
but I've
always been missing
something that you associate with
taste and good taste at the
same time  with a function
or just take vitamins and
where you just feel  okay
you can also record something like that outside of
sports in the office or
if you are out and about somewhere
you can have the drinks at any time
and yes then we are somehow or
I then came up with the idea of ​​simply talking to those
around me about
what we are  for opportunities
and yes it was a very very long
process were now more than two years that have
invested
yes well most people think I
think it can be done within weeks
maybe a month or two
but I'm kind of the type of guy who if
he's into something in  Head
that really wants to do it really well
and
also needs a professional team
with experience with people who are
also familiar with it because as a layman
I have no idea how
to build something like this and what you need for
it
so it's just important that you
also have a good team around you
and then it just took two years
with you  I show 15 rounds of tasting
to meet the perfect tastes and it was a lot of
fun I have to say because you get into new
areas that you don't even
know and yes in the end we are
finally on the market
but in the end it's about that
So drink a sports drink or no,
that’s called repeat at Marco Reus,
so how did that come about? I mean, you
obviously don’t do
everything yourself operationally, but
you’re still
very busy with professional football, that
means you kind of have  you found the
people who do it for you, who bill for the
production, who also market
it, accounting, everything is part of it,
who does it and how do you
relate to one another,
my immediate environment, my consultant,
my my wife, is also involved a
bit as an external consultant
and then  nor with Ole Schaumberg, who
simply knows what is going on with
food, how to put something
together w  hat you have to keep in mind and
there is just a good team
set up right now and say in the end
is a company that you probably
now own a large part of and then
take it as it is always better than a
smaller part then your partner
exactly and  So that means you
could also imagine one day
saying okay if it keeps getting
bigger then you really get into it
full-time and do some kind of
sales somehow talk
internationally with some
retail chains what you
do so that's not a project where
I say it
will take a year or so
now and we just want to
sell sell sell it
's just a project that we
want to continue what we want to build up
where
we want to release various other varieties soon it
was like that or if you now  just
like that in Germany dealing with the
company and startups and stuff like that
then falls  t that
's just in the food area so a
lot of new things have been around for a few
years so there's so ankerkraut
spices you may have seen
there's oatli so this oat milk
there's recently a podcast wi-food such
an eat that  you can practically drink there
are a lot of things that suddenly become
big become really big
somehow in this sector in this food sector that
was also the idea man that is
a sector that could be exciting because
it is happening so much right now or was that
for you  really purely from the
product logic i need a drink, [ __ ]
doesn't matter what else it is i'm
making a drink yes so the thought really was
i really want to do it
and then it's just important that of
course you have people around you
who of course also do it  Have a clue
because I I know I don't know
how to set up something like that, everything that goes with it
and we really
thought about it for a long time b  before
we even did a first tasty
round but in the end we've
been out for a good week now and
it's really weird
to see and find your own drink in the shop I have to say
where you can find Rewe Wasgau Familie
Trinkgut Globus
Edeka are so and what is also totally
involved yourself, so if you
somehow make a first appointment at Edeka
to get to know each other you said okay
then I have to come with you or have your
colleagues so that I like or you have to
come with you then you get the appointment or
or  we had a lot of conversations
at Rewe, we were here in Dortmund
, so to speak, in an interview
yes, of course you are not used to everything
and of course everything is then
new for you, but it was incredibly
interesting because you just get
to know new people and their perspectives
and like them  simply work differently than
perhaps in the sports sector,
although of course it is also about
selling and purchasing
and it was great fun
to be there and to simply experience the individual
steps but it is also
available nationally as not only from
Dortmund to West Germany but
it is somehow in Hamburg here with us
or somewhere in Munich nobody buys
that's exactly how it is now  Little by
little the drinks are arriving everywhere
at Marco Reus there is that too I
think
I think it will sell best
there but the feeling is
probably okay and but how do
I have to introduce you to it, so you have
it at Rewe or Edeka, so to speak
in the appointment and then
marvel at first everything again Marco
Reus suddenly stands in the conference room and
tells you that you should soon list this
drink
yes something like that
I would describe it already of
course you knew each other I mean rewe is
also a partner of  from Borussia
Dortmund but of course it's
different if you say i for your own
drink  I would like to advertise and
yes, because you just
want to list the advantages over and when,
so to speak, there will be the first figures where
you know how it sold because
I mean in the end something like this is on the market
, then you don’t get immediate
feedback, but at some point  I
imagine everyone is now waiting very curiously
we are the sales figures how what are
you satisfied with in the end is Rewe or is it
Edeka because I think they buy from
you but in the hope that I can
then sell it myself
but first have to see it exactly  So I
think in the next 1 maximum
two weeks I think we will get the
first numbers
as it looks like it has arrived
I mean we are not in
everything right now but it is
really coming last week when it
started and now  this week it
goes on, I think in the next
two weeks we will get the first
numbers, we are now ahead  no
with the ones with the displays when you
go into the supermarket, for example
Hamburg in Hamburg with Stani softer because
really big Rewe made really
nice and he also found a bit of
space for me
the former St Pauli player in
Hamburg is a legend here by
now  A relatively large food
retailer has a reason for having large
markets here and there,
so to speak, you used the short line and
the person somehow you have a place
for me,
yes, we knew each other a
bit when he was still a trainer
, we used to have each other from time to time
I saw him from time to time and I just found him sensational as a
guy. It's a shame that he
hasn't continued to do this job until now,
but
I told him that he should concentrate on it again
simply because
then because he's a good guy and because
I think I was also a good coach and
he said let's see I know of
course that he now has a lot to
do with d
But of course I was happy
that he said he would do it in
Hamburg and yes, I was there two
or three weeks ago, I was his
guest and I talked to him a little bit about
something like that right away
somehow, so to speak, people came into the store, so
what you there, so to speak, publicly, or
was it more like behind the scenes, you
have behind the scenes, so
was on the road before and
then we said, come on, let's
stop by Stani's and he was there too
we talked a bit
and tell me, do you
also use your networker, so to speak, that your
teammates now also how does
that somehow motivate your colleague
Hummels and otherwise there would be
something like that in the camera
or
I have to say I am  now not
the type who
likes to approach people openly and
says hey please post for me I
'm just not me but if then
should d  The boys should be
able to decide for themselves, of course
, the boys will get nice packages
with a few bottles and
accessories in them, but in the end
it's just up to them
because I'm just not that type of
person, I have to say that one over there  goes so openly
and then says hey post now
because I need the support
if of course nice so if
someone hears that from the boys very much
likes
yes you look at this this
lion's den yourself sometimes because
I think that's a too  Product
that you could tend to push with such a
show and
I think all the other food companies just
spoke, they also
pitched some of them on TV somehow before then
Ralf Dümmel and Georg Kofler and
and whatever their names are, you watch something like this
as a viewer  at least once
i have to say i watch very little
tv okay
yes i have to say the tv is
actually always off ic  I don't even know
why I still have one,
but somehow I almost never
watch TV anymore, but of course
you noticed that with the lion's cave and
with all the startup companies
that are shown to everyone, I think there are
a few cool people there and a few
cool ideas
but I don't know if that's something for us now
, we'll just have to see
how things are going and in which
direction summer will go in the next few
weeks and months
because you're so little done
watching TV you're
also surprised  no soccer either, I
mean, you’re just a kid, I would
have somehow thought that
when you play on Saturday you watch the Sunday
games or watch Champions League games
when you’re not
playing yourself or
something else, but my daughter tells me
okay, but she’s sleeping too  at 9 a.m.
Tuesday Wednesday so
that would definitely be possible
but mostly yes I do a
bit of re  generation or
just spend a bit of time with my
wife but of course I watch it from time to
time if City is playing against
United then of course you look at it
definitely okay
but not now somehow no
excessive football consumption actually
also own lately  it has
really become less I
honestly don’t know why so
clearly family in any case simply
because you’re on the road so much anyway, every week you’re on the road for
at least three or four days
and then you want to be able to spend
time with me when you’re at home
spend with the family and then
there are other things to do,
so it's a bit shorter at the moment,
but to be honest I don't think it's that
bad at all because you're
actually connected to football
every day and you
think about aroma from there every day  it's also
good if you've had a little
time to think about other things,
tell me  How much do you have to
imagine it costs to
build up your company, so if you have a
startup like this, you are normally talking about
millions of sums that you have to
invest to even get such
a bottle started and
to have the first
products  what can you take us by the hand
you give an order of magnitude so now
certainly we probably do
n't want to say an exact amount but that
order of magnitude communion will
cost nope not that much depends
on which team
you have and of course you want to be in  Invest in good
quality and invest in
a good product,
but really large amounts in the millions
don't come from this situation simply
because we worked really
meticulously and took our time
and didn't just take the
best thing first,
but simply made sure
that it just takes time  a
little longer until we're outside
It's a shame, of course, because you always
think okay when you start with it, then
you want to be out there as soon as
possible and present it to the
people, but we just took
a little extra time
, simply with a view to the
fact that it's not just a one-time action  is
that it simply has a future
and that you can simply work with this product and with
this brand,
so of course it was expensive now, so
we don't need to talk about it
, but it was definitely worth it, okay,
okay, and so far there have been no
professionals  -investors, so to speak,
not venture capital,
or only you know it,
venture capitalists of some form,
but in the end you financed this sum for
this result yourself and
and the team worked, so to speak,
and you put the money in
exactly yes  well that and will not exist now in the
future well because that
's the way it is my my lord  zen matter
my dream too, which I started
and would like to continue and yes
that means you are not looking for any money now either
so if someone says
okay it's just right the time drinks can
be made big somehow can
soon be sold to Coca-Cola
or something like that  and Marco
Reus somehow has a decent range
I'm going with three rubbish now I'd
like to invest so you're not looking for one
either
ne up until now it's not uh to be
honest not that not that debate
probably most of
us will only come up when things are going really well anyway
well, think okay, you can
definitely invest there, but no,
we built the team up in such a
way that yes, that's not
necessary and that wasn't the
plan for the future, I was
somehow inspired to see that it's in
USA something like that happens regularly I
mean there isn't one I know of
some big stars in the USA who are in,
um,
whiskey or
Some of the gin companies built up then sold for billions to the
absurd to also sell athletes
who also
do a lot in the drinks sector, I think there was like
the inspiration or is or is
n’t it actually not at all, so it
wasn’t really right for you
Of
course, to be honest, I have
n't copied anything now, but of
course you get a lot,
like I just said with whiskey and I
couldn't invest a bit in other areas
now, simply because
I wasn't able to
advertise it well enough  or could
probably not go down so well,
that's why it became the repeat vitamin
water and yes, but of course you get
that in America with that of
course totally over there, so what
options do you have there, of course,
more people, so do you have them or
is the probability  even
higher that it works even better
and in America I think it will
People also just celebrated a bit more
than in
Germany, especially as an athlete
, maybe even more will be bought from you,
maybe a little less critically
or something, but things have
not been the case in recent years that
other concepts have also been
presented to you  I mean, you
've been there for ten twelve
years or even longer, so to speak,
in the German perception and you
've somehow always
had relatively good salaries for
normal people since then, um,
we're presented before any other
investments  according to
the motto know here startup
you can be there there is some kind of new
website I mean that's in the
Bundesliga I don't know for
years that from time to time the
stars are also so nice yes of
course there was  that also in the
past but it wasn't
like I said but awesome project kla
r that always sounded good, but I've
always been a fan of it, I just wanted to do
something of
my own, wanted to have my own finger in the pie,
just wanted to decide for myself
which way to go
and if you buy yourself somewhere
then yes, that's how it is  yes, let the
others work for it and
then I am so happy that I like to
do it myself under my 40 years and
just like to make the decision
myself with the
others and yes I am very, very
happy that it is the way it is  it's now
with you in general like your your numbers
economic planning also a lot like
gut feeling I mean you've now made a
career that with your
skills you could
probably have chosen other
careers so that's probably
always had the chance, for example in
the other  to change leagues to go abroad
but you get the feeling it's
a bit of a bug with you  n bit of
gut feeling or with the
actual desire not to do that or
or
are you annoyed afterwards or do you say
you didn't get the chance
on the are fooling yourself so how is that
who advises you how do you do that
the chance  there has been
in the past
, especially in the mid-20s
to just very young and
there was still the opportunity
to do something else, but it was
just always important
to me, my family around me  to have a
good environment around me and
then I just don't need any
change so
it becomes clear or have there been
moments where I might have thought it
would have been really cool if you
if you had maybe done something else
but on the other hand I did
I just felt so good
and
I just didn't need anything new because I have
enough to do here I have to manage a
lot  I have a responsibility and yes,
I grew into it in the last few years.
I
think I've been a captain for the third or fourth
year
I have to and I'm
just glad that my career went the
way it did because it could have gone
differently, so I
'm proud of it too, but have you noticed
such a change in the Bundesliga in the last few years
that
actually every star is now  that you
play in addition to yourself after
a certain period of time
either goes to Spain
it wasn’t like that before, I
mean when you know you weren’t somehow 15 16
there was somehow Bayern Munich
felt like the end goal and
now it’s okay actually  everyone comes to
Dortmund and then they go to Spain
or England so it
feels even worse different before a
pa  ar years actually
it
is always difficult
to speak for others in general but you can say
that
it is of course always very difficult for the German
clubs for the German league
simply
because they of course have less money
than in England or in some cases  also
in Spain
that it's just difficult to bring the
absolute top players to Germany
, because there are simply not enough clubs in Germany
that have these financial
opportunities, of course,
that's not even a question and of course they and the
players want to
win and of course want to
earn money we don't need to
talk about that and I always see it
in Dortmund it's always a shame
to see that we sign incredibly good
players young players they
unfortunately just have the dream of
wanting to play somewhere else after
two three four years maybe and
just continue there
because ma  n always has the feeling okay now
you could build a team and
then in two years the team breaks up
again because two three good
players just leave and if you
just look at which players we
really had in the last few years
we would, I think if they
would have stayed together I think
a lot would be shaved in Europe absolutely and
yes but it's just the
football business everyone has their
own goals that they pursue their
own ideas and
really only everyone can
really decide for themselves but generally for
the German league  Of course it would be
nicer if there were more commitments
, we would now at Bayern Manet,
for example, that's the way of course,
as the people have a lot of
desires and of course it makes the league
much more interesting, but in
general I still
think that we have a good position
because  we have good players because we have good ones
too  clubs we have
unbelievable fans in the Bundesliga
I think you can say that and that is
also worth a lot. Tell me a very
short fan question from me. As a
football fan I have to briefly
explain all the people you’ve met in
the last  years together
who were the one two
where they were just really the most
crassest gamblers really difficult I
have to say where I came to Dortmund back then
I hope I
said that a few times
I think Mario Götze was the exception
really talent he was unbelievable back
then it was really unbelievable that
I think everyone I
spoke to and who saw him
play in those years
said that otherwise we had an
unbelievable number of good players
James Sancho at Dortmund  an
incredibly good player because he simply has
incredibly good timing coupled with dribbling, also when it comes to
a pass  it
just has momentum you have to mention the evidence as well
in the minimal as the man without
hips because he can turn so quickly
Honestly back then
Ilkay I think I forgot a
few but I think those are the ones
that say the most impressive
I once left her business card
and but tell me if you
just say you do
n't watch football yourself so often but when
you watch then you
say you always watch United vs City
so that means you watch even when
you yourself  you watch the premier league rather than the
bundesliga to
be honest yes
because it's better sport or because it's
just even more
crass no somehow i don't know why she
recognizes it from the FF no and of
course you can also know the
premier league but I think it's a
special game if  if you play against
United then you just meet two
great teams opposite with
great players
who know the Bundesliga  Of course a
bit so it's difficult to
explain but yes you look then I
'd rather watch the Premier
League or La Liga when water
plays against row tell me now back to
economic issues
you're just following the course of the Bundesliga
as such as a platform  now not
great that somehow the other
platforms the others have more
money and I club then all have
more money then look
at e.g. what is Donata Hopfen doing now somehow
that he is the new DFL boss
you probably noticed that she is
now or taking  you
're observing
something like they're doing now, all the discussions about whether a playoff should be introduced in the Bundesliga,
you're following something like that,
partly partly, I would say, so it's
not that I'm
looking at it every two days, okay  What
news is there? Back then,
the idea of ​​this Super League came up
again  bt it's now with the
playoffs I've actually always been a
fan of them I should somehow everyone
grew up should stay the way it
is and if in the end the team is at the
top after 34 match days then
they deserve to be the champions and
it's always a bit difficult, of
course you always want to
bring something new to people because everyone
on the right is always looking for something
new and first I have to change something,
some areas might be okay, but
I'm actually already a fan of it,
just that a lot of things are closed  leave it as it
is but of course there are just changes in the
world in general
that we can't decide that
I think was also an important point
simply other people have more
power but I still think you
should also involve the clubs and the
players  involve in the
decisions but it's also a
bit annoying 15 years ago there were
at least a few ve  r different
German champions now with Bayern it's
really crazy that they actually
win every year isn't it
a little bit for you what you think okay it's
just annoying that you're so good but
still don't really stand a chance because
the others just have more
money and  can clearly
do good work every year but it's also
the budget is a lot bigger
yes of course it's annoying so
we'd also like to have another
German champion in our place of
course
but yes I mean if you now I do
n't know how often you do that
have become champions in a row 10 11 years
then it's not free either of
course it has something to do with the financial
situation
but nevertheless it also has something
to do with performance and they have
simply done better work in the last few years
and we just come
at the moment  not not about
being consistent and
just having this constancy I think you
just need al  s Borussia Dortmund if possible
34 matchdays at the maximum and
you also need a lot of luck in many games
to really be German
champions in the end because Bayern simply has
this consistency and if they always
don’t have it then it has to be there and
if you don’t  then it gets
difficult and it's not
always as easy as people
might think sometimes if Bayern are weak
then you have to be there
it always sounds easier than it is
and we're working really, really hard
on it mentally too because  it's also mentally
important that you're there in
crucial situations
, it's such a simple process in many areas
and you just
have to keep believing in it, you just have to do
more than what we're doing now,
let's say that in the end it's leadership responsibility for you too
somehow
, the proximity between sport and
business is not so far
apart that you just said that
you d  as you also had to learn first to get
into such a management
responsibility criteria is
to be the face, so to speak, also
somehow to lead the hierarchy
what was it like for you so I
mean in the business wave is also
like that you start when we start normally and
Suddenly you are then in the
head fasting department what were they for
you the one two things that were so crucial for you
really new for me as
a leader so to speak
because I have to say I have
n’t actually changed much now,
I’m just really like that
remained as I am and with some of
course you have a different
area of ​​responsibility if you if you are captain
if you have to lead a team
if you have to hold talks
then sometimes it's a bit tougher
then you just have to say yes a little
from the outside from the outside  look okay what
's the mood like who
might need a private conversation who
might need a  n are accepted a bit
harder then it’s just a bit a matter of
feeling and you just get to know that
over the months or over the years
, of course you’re
always responsible because you
’re always the first to have to take a stand on
it, for example after  the
game when it when it when you lost
but the things
just add to that and you get to
know them anew week after week and there was
n’t such a glaring
incision I
kept calmly saying wow
I wouldn’t have it now  thought
tell me was already aware you are a
captain of a very, very big club
and there is also responsibility and then
you are definitely proud that
you can lead the team onto the field
do you follow the
discussion about the national team
somehow too  relatively narrow because there
was this big debate recently,
also such a business world or
marketing world that the irge  And what the name of the
team is and then it’s
no longer called that is what you perceive
as a player, so to speak, the whole
marketing topic around it
, of course you get that with it
, it’s very clear,
there’s always hot man, I say it’s
always a fine line, I
mean  A few years ago, in 2014, we were also the
team and somehow it
didn't bother anyone and now we
didn't have a good tournament in 2018
220 wasn't an outstanding
tournament either because of course we had a different
goal, but then of course people let themselves in
a bit  a little bit
after that okay what can you change what
bothers you what bothers people
yes now it's gone I don't think so
anymore but for us players it
really doesn't matter what we're called
, we're
still a team and whether it's
the team now  means or
quite normal the national team that
's really
secondary to us to be honest
leadership There are quite a few people in the football environment,
so I mean we
just talked about what you could
say to actively get involved more
than than than as training, but I
mean you also have something to do with the
box, so be it
club bosses or trainers or
teammates are there
any leaders who say
okay, super impressive, I was
able to learn a lot from that because people are
particularly good at it,
somehow  are of
course you absorb a
bit and
look so okay in which moments
maybe how do you behave and
what is your speech like
but I have always been a friend
of
observing things of course but
implementing them yourself the way you
feel at the moment because  only in this way do I believe that
I can continue to develop if you
copy a lot then you are not speaking
directly  en sense but
another person and I have now typed
that you probably somehow
mention Klopp because after everything
one hears he must be the most blatant managerial and
leadership guy, so to speak, who
gives us such a
thing, yes he was brutal, I really have to
say that  very first time I
met him at the
Dortmund office
yes absolutely tree stood in front of you an aura
that you really can not describe
is of course big and I think it
has gained a bit of
weight in the meantime
no fun yes it was really cool
to meet him just  because yes would just
have a certain aura you
just feel so under the spell
and
yes won't say anything now don't dare
to say anything but you just listen
spellbound and definitely stand there
differently than maybe when other
trainers speak and that  was very
very exciting to watch and i had
them really many years and he was
really e  in an outstanding trainer who can
also be very very angry at times
but was that with him or also because you
already knew he is very successful
or was it just
out of your own mind so regardless of your nerves
meanwhile it's so big as a
person that  they say okay the guy is
right anyway because he just
kind of
illustrates the successes but back then there were
n’t that many successes actually no it
started
back then I switched in 2012 and then
I think they became second to each other  Champion
and once cup winner after double
that year but he
wasn't perceived as Jürgen
Klopp I think he is today
and then he
just developed further but
I think I just stayed true to himself
I think he has  just barely
changed it still has the same
facial features in the game as it did ten
years ago and I think that
may be  en simply the people and yes
you also get that he has become an outstanding
coach that I have also
developed there and I built up my
water with us back then, he
built that up at Liverpool and now
over the years I think I’ve always been at the top in
recent years  I've always been in the
Champions League final,
so the work and the success speaks
for itself. What's the matter, that's the one
topic that's meant, he's a massive guy, so to speak,
that you
can somehow draw a line straight away, but are there
still some sort of things
that  you can maybe learn from it
so he is particularly empathetic has such
a good feeling for people is very
funny does he have it or does he have a sense of humor or
I mean is everything in that
respect he just has a plan for
football we also have a lot of people because we feel it
should too  other people who now,
let's say, can explain a pressure well, so to speak, that's
not his only skill, I g  I believe
that he can deal with people incredibly well
, so he can insult you
,
Canadian exaggeratedly, in training
and can also get on your sack and
yes, he yells at you, but after
training he comes up to you and
hugs you  and
asked if everything is okay and how is the
family and
yes it's such a mix easy and
you just feel well
positioned you feel important you
have the support of the trainer
and it's just a good feeling and
again many many  I think the
players said
you like to walk through fire for the trainer,
simply because he is there with such an
emotional level, it is
actually
usually a bit of a business
system to do with you in the dressing room,
now
investing in some kind of money is
kind of an issue  but then you see
each other exchanging ideas I mean it's
somehow hopefully known that you
all earn well and now you're doing
soz  usagen your own company but
let’s say the topic Wisely not
crypto bitcoin have you talked about it in the last few
years is there like
an exchange or someone says hey I
had something back then or I have something there or
maybe even shares that someone
has I have here  invested in it or
any other start-up ideas or
is that still not talk about it
in the dressing
room but it is clear that you are your
people with whom you are talking about it and I also
believe that many are already
doing something in the background simply
because they see  because the market or
the opportunities are just so great
these days to invest in different things
or to bring them to the market yourself
and
that's why we naturally
also talk about it at home, so to be honest I don't know that well about stocks,
or we don't at all  had last
year when Marvin Hitz was still with us I think
it can be really good with
it and ha  t you can have them explain a little bit
I think that everyone
just takes a look for themselves
okay where where does he feel comfortable where
maybe he wants to invest
that is but I think he’s
really free to do it simply because you
still have so many options and what
you’re doing  because you're doing
real estate somehow, you're somehow
buying a few apartments here in Dortmund
or something, what are you doing, I
mean, you have to invest it somehow,
logically, of
course, I've also invested in a
lot of real estate, simply because it
's money well invested  stones are
always good I would say so you
can't do anything wrong I think
better than
having it in our account I think we have Borussia Dortmund
shares you also have your
own club I mean you can
do Borussia too  Dortmund is also
listed on the stock exchange, you could somehow
say okay, this year I feel good,
I'll buy a few
Shares, yes, but I haven't
done it until now, I just don't
feel comfortable with it, so there's
generally a bit of a distortion of competition with us
investing in money anyway,
and that's an issue
because we're always checked a bit before the season, no
I'd rather keep my hands off
it because everything happens so quickly these days
and then you're put in the wrong light
and I don't want
to have anything to do with you anymore okay okay that means your
thing is now first of all thank you very much
repeat what is the goal  so
you have there is a business plan, at least
something you looked at okay
with that you can now somehow in the
next few years the thing will
somehow make five or ten or 20
million in sales or even more or 100
or is there such a thing
Order of magnitude that precedes you so
the turnover is concerned
no, to be honest, not so
the idea behind it is just to
keep going, well  to
look naturally okay how's it going now how
are people getting on i think it's
just a very important topic
because of course it's not that
cheap now other drinks
might cost 80 90 or 1 euro it
now costs 1970 for example and that for them
People, of course, in the current world, of
course, also a lot of money, and
then in the future we will simply see,
so we let ourselves be
surprised a bit, you also had to look a
little,
how do you say it,
how it how it how it
runs and then just bring in new ideas,
but the goal is
definitely
to keep going, to bring out new varieties, to
become
even healthier in the
event of changes,
but we really take our
time, how many bottles do you drink
a day, so let's be honest  Statement if
you now how many how many of them
are in it how many milliliters 500
milliliters drink how much Marco Reus
I drink a lot myself,
I have to say, I also
drink normal water, which in any case
simply because it is also important,
but I drink a lot,
so of course we have training every day
and I have the boys with us
at the  The site is already a bit
supplied with it and I can say that it
is definitely going away very well,
which is of course a good sign, but
in principle I drink a
lot of bottles a day and I mean
I was wondering because it was sweet too
is how does it work because you said
yes without sugar and you already
explained in the preliminary talk that it
is agave thick juice that you put in there,
so to speak natural sugar it is
already sugar so it has
more calories but it is somehow
anyway  better than if you
somehow drink a cola now, logically,
yes, that's definitely always
making the comparison with coal, of course, it's
extremely
wi  There really is a lot of sugar in it, but
we work with agave syrup and
it's the healthier sugar and it's
just incredibly difficult to
bring out
a flavored vitamin water where you still have a taste but
have little sugar in it and that's why
we take so much time  relaxed
simply because we wanted it to be perfect
and of course there is
a certain standard in the sugar area where you
can also be called low shower, for example,
and we are
low sugar, for example, and yes it's
just incredibly difficult and
you really have to think about it okay
where  do you just set the limit and I
think the tastes
hit it really well,
yes, and if
you say okay, so to speak,
I don't know so far, I somehow
drink another drink of this kind anyway,
which could it be, so what does it
have to do now, so to speak  from
people's shopping baskets,
that used to be hope but not Isostar or or
me  I also know in the past there was always
something from Boris Becker called
what he always drank, so
according to advertising
from the gate trade I don't
know how it's active or where it's
always called, you get red hair
because where  it's a bakery somehow that's
knowledge do you remember
sports drinks so there are others
so what what is its competition
I now think, for example, that
vitamins well I think it's about the
same in our area I
honestly don't know how expensive they are
but I do  knows, for example, that they have
more sugar than we do, for
example, because people naturally
ask for it nowadays, of course, a lot of
everything is vegan and little sugar and many
other areas where people just
pay attention, of course we
also paid attention to that, but of course you're
in  there are also many competitors in the industry
and
you might have to, it does
n't even work that's a
lot more, I think  h on sugar and
other things beings that already vitamin
water so that's again
I think another another
term say finally
another topic
are you actually also active in the
whole area of ​​eSports so kind of
gaming  is it also for that I
mean there is a mother a
community where people buy something like that when in doubt
is also sport absolutely yes
that's why I say yes this drink
is not only for athletes but
even if it's me athletes now
but sit down  also at home or in front of the
screen somewhere else and of
course you also
have your own area and I think that this
area has just come to an extreme,
I think in America it’s significantly
more than it is here, but
I think we’re getting one
Community just built up with
eSportler with Twitch
with all the trappings that come up a
bit and yes you are there so
gamble  you are part of it so
you know it from your own experience
so you are, let's say we
like to do it with your free time
to gamble or something from time
to time so now we have less FIFA and
more a bit of Call of Duty
there are many in our
team who like to gamble a lot
and then you connect a
bit and yes nowadays
through all the headphones and you
can stay in touch very well
but that doesn’t mean FIFA so much for you
but  when you say
Call of Duty or something like that, I
have to say I used to play a lot of
FIFA too, my younger ones, but
now it’s kind of wandered a bit
and
with you as a character sometimes so
what you then played Marco Reus yourself
, of course I sometimes played with you  played by
myself is normal I would be lying
if I didn't say it
's not like that on the
FIFA cover myself which is also very very s  It
was special, of course, you
played it yourself, but you also receded
into the background
a bit and now we’re doing something different.
One day maybe the coach
or the sports director will be out,
so the
coaching area at the top is really
professional football  I don't
think I'll see me so no for that I think the
footballer has also changed a bit
and is very very much
I would become media and the pressure
is always there but we don't need to
talk
but I like being a person who
also just likes to be left alone
and also like to be at home with families
and friends and because I also like to spend time with
the people but I
like to work with children, for example, so I
could
easily imagine becoming a youth coach, of course
you are one too  a little bit of
course on the go but just like that to
help the boys
advance with what
I would have to teach  on it
yes that is the final question so to speak of
course it has to come what is
in it this year so to speak
national team and and and club
what do you think what what can you what what
can you get
how every year a lot
no so you will just see it
national team like
I said before you just need a
lot of stability you just need consistency
above all in the
results that you can't always
play outstanding football
I think it's normal but you just need
consistency in the performances in the
results
and  then you will simply see and
then in the end you will simply observe
okay what was it enough for and with the
national team of course we have the World Cup
just around the corner I believe that we have
now performed well in the Nations League
that we have a
good squad  but
it's the same thing again you need a tournament of course you also need
luck you have to you
mu  sst be there when it matters
and one will just take a look but
would so I mean is it for you I am
asking really naively is it safe that you will come along so
there is so is I don’t know anyone
yet but it is so you assume so
Current status I don't think so,
there isn't a squad yet,
logically,
but one would now expect that
you would come along, no, I assume
so, if they don't
suddenly change something suddenly, um, I'm injured
or whatever
, I'm going now  but assuming
that the national coach, as
has often been said in the media, is
what counts and we have so many good
German
national players in our ranks who
show good performance yes everyone has to be
typically modest of you now we are
speaking here on the Monday
after  first day of the game and you
also helped to get the first three points significantly
when that goal was scored
somehow a week  nende so that
means without your goal the three
points won't be there insofar as it's going
quite well
yes but you never want me your life
or have never seen me in the
past that I
praise myself or I celebrate myself
so that  I'm just the Hennig type
and I just stayed
too
modest for that simply
because it was put in my
way and simply because
I'm just not that type of guy and that's why
the team is always in the foreground and
when the team is good  plays and
wins then automatically plays well too,
so the first step is always
let me say that the team
works well and then you
can get away with it yourself let's say because
that's for me personally at the
weekend I just told you  in the
preliminary talk tells a book read 500
pages book about how three young people were
observed for ten years in
their junior academies like s  he
wanted to be a professional soccer player one of
them really made it in the end
by chance through luck so
that just worked out for you
in the team of Marius Wolf the
other two just
stopped playing soccer at some point or ended up in
some lower-class
hobby teams although they are also
great  even one of
them was even an international player
but didn't get any
further it was always
clear to you what you were so outstanding so in the
book you can also read that with
some people something always clear Timo
Werner must always have been so strong  be
you knew everything already he was
outstanding when you look at your career
then I asked myself was
that also so that you
thought meanwhile okay professional football it wo
n't be anything anymore or or was it
always clear
no it wasn't even clear so there was
also  sometimes phases for example when you
think okay you're in the Jugendve  If you come to
Borussia Dortmund, then of
course the rush to
start your career in the
professional field is of course very large and
most of the time it's really like that if
you maybe take an intermediate
step it may sound like a step backwards to outsiders but
it's for you for development
simple step forward because you
just play, so I would
always advise every young player, okay, just switch
to a club that plays there,
where you can develop further,
just where you are of course at a
level, I would also have others on my
radar
but it doesn't necessarily have to be
at Borussia Dortmund
or at Bayern Munich in the youth
or in Leverkusen in the youth
I don't know there are many
examples that have made it
elsewhere and of course you need a
lot of luck in those
decisive moment simply to be yes
gesi  right to become and someone to simply have
a sponsor who says okay
I really want to keep the young ones
yes but I would
always advise the young players who are definitely young to
always play and what was what for you,
so to speak, the one there was at the moment  where you
say okay if the guy hadn't
seen me or if I hadn't
played there or that was sort of
because the key from sort of
almost filling up with soccer and
becoming an amateur soccer player to now you
're sort of a national or European
superstar so there was such a one
A moment when that was okay, that all
changed for me, because I simply had cream
,
which is difficult to say, I did back
then, I think B B1, I think
I switched to everyone in the half-year
and of course it was like that
for me at first  Gotta be
gone from Borussia Dortmund and if it had
actually been two or three years
to the professional field, the step was
worth its weight in gold for me because I was a Dor  tmund
didn't play either or didn't play that
much and it was
just great for my development because
I was
able to play in my position in everyone where I see myself
because we then played A-Youth
Bundesliga and after that it was just a 2
Liga and then I actually went
straight up to majugend
yes and that was just for my
development it was really great and
I had Christian
wöckwarttrainer at the time who was always
happy to
develop development players
and of course I was lucky there
just being promoted there at the same time
getting the hardship of the second
division because it's just something different from
the first division and yes,
one thing leads to another then the
self-confidence came back, which you
lost a bit in your
youth because you  didn't play much
then it's really important that you
keep pushing yourself this
year  You simply develop through games,
through match practice and through successes and
then I just played in the second division for a year
and then I just went to
Gladbach where Max Eber signed
me okay so in the end I had
a bit of these basking situations
, that's exactly it  who played then
or in the league would
n’t have either, so it’s not like that anymore either,
so you have it somehow was
n’t clear that you would now
come out as the Dortmund captain and national player, so to speak, it
could have just gone differently,
you can  read this book horny
and really know it like that I went
through the whole weekend 500
pages and
then always told you okay Monday
spokesman with Marco Reus and Marius Wolf
again the daughter was positioned on the course as a
coincidence and
somehow he has been ten years  his
parents probably decided that for him that
he that that the editor there or the
Ronald Tr  änen that's the name of the author
superauthor allowed to accompany and then it
was a funny story anyway, stories are no
so you have to say yes
so mostly you can say yes okay
these are coincidences that happened
but they are just awesome stories
for the people around how something like this
comes about  what goes with it is just
a great experience for
oneself, no, because I don't think marius said at the time
where he started it
, okay, I'll definitely be a professional
soccer player, but there
have also been steps
that weren't planned
Luck have been connected
and of course we could also join at the same time,
but otherwise it wouldn't have
made it, so I think
every professional can
tell his or her own story and there will probably be
exciting topics on the table, yes,
thank you very much for the time, it's
training again in the afternoon  announced or
what somehow but okay okay so
many there  nk that we
were of course allowed to speak here on a day off
everything will be drinks
exactly
okay thank you good luck in the
next few months and yes I will watch it on
the many thanks all the best
stay healthy ciao ciao this podcast
is produced by potsstars
at OMR